eu sei que a facilidade de fritar um ovo
na frigideira de teflon deixa a gente
tentado é muito prático mas infelizmente
algumas facilidades e praticidades vem
acompanhadas de um preço alto a se pagar
e esse preço pode ser caro pra sua saúde
Qual será o tipo de panela mais saudável
para cozinhar ou fritar o seu alimento é
o que eu vou responder nesse vídeo de
acordo com os meus estudos e pesquisas
até o momento Então vamos para o que
você está tanto esperando eu fiz uma
lista das melhores das piores panelas
para você cozinhar vou primeiro falar
das piores panelas aquelas que você
realmente deve eliminar da sua cozinha e
depois vou falar das melhores vamos lá
começo a lista com a pior de todas as
panelas que é a de teflon essas panelas
possuem revestimento com muitos produtos
químicos prejudiciais à saúde de um modo
geral esse revestimentos de teflon são
feitos de compostos
perfurados que são altamente txicos e
que permanecem por muito tempo no meio
ambiente também chamados de pfcs da
sigla inglês são feitos à base de fluor
e muitos deles não foram devidamente
testados quanto ao impacto da Saúde os
vapores que saem da panela revestida por
teflon quando aquecidos não comete
somente pessoas Mas podem ser inclusive
fatais para animais com pássaros ou
papagaios se respirarem conforme o tempo
passa você percebe que o revestimento da
panela vai se desgastando talvez você
não tenha se perguntado até hoje para
onde vai essa camada tóxica que some com
tempo Será que ela vai parar em seu
alimento ou melhor dentro de você uma
coisa é certa se ela some ela tem que ir
para algum lugar a segunda pior panela
são as de alumínio o alumínio das
panelas podem reagir com substâncias
mais ácidas como tomates ou frutas
cítricas então é claro que haverá
liberação de alumínio na sua comida bom
mas você pode pensar assim minha avó
cozinhou quase a vida inteira em panelas
de alumínio e morreu com mais de 100
anos e lúcida mas pessoal ela com
certeza ingeria alumínio das panelas
porém antigamente não tinha o excesso
absurdo de contaminantes tóxicos que
temos hoje muitos produtos que você
passa na pele contém alumínio seu
desodorante Favorito pode ter Alumínio
São outros tempos onde estamos nos
intoxicando por todos os lados a carga
tóxica é muito maior quando ingerimos
pequenas quantidades de alumínio
diariamente e por um tempo podemos
acumular no organismo e nos órgãos
trazendo riscos à saúde em especial
quando você está intoxicado demais e seu
fígado e outros órgãos estão trabalhando
em hora extra para não te deixar doente
existem evidências de que a maior
concentração de alumínio no corpo está
relacionada à doença de alzheimer embora
existam ainda estudos conflitantes sobre
isso o alumínio interfere com a absorção
do selênio do fósforo no seu organismo
Ele é é tóxico porque se liga enzimas e
proteínas substituindo outros metais que
são importantes pro nosso corpo os
sintomas relacionados a intoxicação por
alumínio incluem diminuição da
capacidade intelectual perda de massa
óssea dificuldade de concentração e
fácil esquecimento das coisas além do
Mal de Alzheimer o alumínio pode estar
envolvido no Mal de Parkinson além de
doenças neurológicas doenças do sistema
esquelético constipação intestinal
náuseas na anorexia fadiga e doenças do
sangue ou hematológicas se você não
consegue comprar uma panela das mais
caras e seguras você pode comprar uma
panela de inox por exemplo da Tramontina
com fundo triplo e Revestimento de
cerâmica ou mesmo uma panela apenas de
inox com fundo triplo as panelas de inox
São relativamente seguras não são as
melhores Então classifico como sendo
medianas na questão de liberação de
resíduos tóxicos agora eu vou falar do
meu top três panelas mais seguras para
você cozinhar a primeira delas são as
panelas de vidro o vidro sempre foi
considerado material bastante seguro e
não tóxico para ser usado na cozinha Se
você tem aquela forma quadrada ou
redonda feita de alumínio Não pense duas
vezes antes de jogá-la no lixo compre
uma travessa de vidro própria para assar
alimentos de vidro temperado pois elas
são Preparadas para suportar altas
temperaturas claro sempre procure uma
marca confiável no mercado OK o problema
é que a maioria dos utensilos de vidro
não podem ser usados no fogão porque não
aguenta a variação de temperatura
portanto use vidro temperado existem
panelas de vidro que podem ser
utilizados no fogão forno e freezer são
os de vidro temperado que são adequados
para suportar altas temperaturas mais
importante é pesquisar nas instruções do
fabricante se o utensílio de vidro pode
ser utilizado no fogão posso recomendar
a maca de panelas de vidro Vision porém
são panelas mais difíceis de achar hoje
em dia já a segunda da lista das tops
são as panelas de cerâmica a as panelas
de cerâmica são muito seguras mas é
sempre importante prestar atenção no
esmalte que reveste a parte interna se
esse esmalte ou tinta tiver alguma
substância tóxica como chumbo cadmio
isso pode ser um problema para sua saúde
então sempre consulte o fabricante e
busque uma marca confiável a cerâmica é
muito parecida com vidro e pode se
quebrar caso caia no chão ou Receba um
choque térmico muito alto são panelas
que você deve ter cuidados especiais
porque os alimentos grudam com mais
facilidade nelas e algumas delas o cabo
acaba esquentando demais isso pode
causar acidentes como queimaduras então
entenda que elas não são tão práticas no
uso mas são muito seguras para cozinhar
Então você deve ter aquela dúvida básica
e me perguntar se as panelas com
revestimento de cerâmica não as de
totalmente cerâmica se esses que só tem
revestimento são boas não pessoal não
são boas porque esse revestimento pode
se soltar assim como o téflon e no fundo
essas panelas tem alumínio que pode
soltar e te contaminar esse tipo de
cobertura de cerâmica costuma ser muito
fraco e quando você ten riscos eh São
liberados partículas de chumbo alumínio
e cádmio metais pesados que
frequentemente são presentes na própria
cobertura que podem passar facilmente
pros alimentos como a cerâmica é um
componente natural e aguenta o calor de
forma muito mais resistente do que o
alumínio ou qualquer outra aplicação uma
panela feita inteiramente desse material
é considerada até o momento 100% segura
e saudável as marcas de panela de
cerâmica que eu indico para você são
tognana frigideira hoen Oxford ceraflame
e neoflam da Extrema consulte sempre as
orientações do fabricante para fazer o
uso correto da panela e verifique os
revestimento não é tóxico para finalizar
a terceira panela mais segura voltando
ao ácio inox é a de grau 316 o ao de
grau cirúrgico sendo considerada uma das
melhores panelas para se cozinhar pois
libera menos substâncias estranhas em
sua comida mas qual seria então a
diferença da panela de inox comum para o
inox cirúrgico o ácido inox cirúrgico
316 contém uma pequena quantidade de
molibidênio ou titânio além do níquel e
Cromo já os benefícios das panelas de
ácido cirúrgico incluem uma resistência
ainda maior a ferrugem e corrosão do que
O acido inox 304 Afinal é utilizado para
implantes biomédicos e também em
ambientes marinhos Pois é praticamente
imune a oxidação as panelas cirúrgicas
de ácido inox geralmente também são bem
mais caras eu posso te recomendar a
panela de ácido cirúrgico inox da marca
Royal Prestige Então pessoal o resumo da
Ópera de um modo geral as panelas 100%
de cerâmica são as melhores em custo
benefício as panelas de vidro e aço de
grau cirúrgico são consideradas as mais
seguras já as panelas de teflon e de
alumínio são as piores possíveis um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração